in my last video i show you how to write
a quantum circuit using kiskit
but i'm sure that you are wondering how
to actually take la quantum program
and rang it on a real quantum
computer
quantum computers have existed since the
1990s but until recently they are only
accessible
to researchers in labs
today quantum computers still require
special equipment and maintenance
but thanks to the development of cloud
technology
anyone can access our quantum computers
through the cloud
today most of the real world quantum
applications
uses some kind of interplay between the
classical and the quantum resources
that is sending my circuits to the real
quantum hardware for execution is only
half of the story
once the program is the circuits are
done being wrong
the quantum hardware returns the results
back to my laptop
my quantum program then does some kind
of classical processing
and the output of this classical
processing is then used to generate the
next sets of circuits to run
unfortunately this is a very inefficient
model
because my real world application can
have hundreds of iterations
and for every single iteration the
circuit
the circuits need to be sent all the way
to the quantum hardware which can be
extremely far away
ellen needs to wait for the result to
again make the return trip just to
generate the circuits for the next
iteration
it is spending more time on the data
transfer than actual execution
and this is why in 2021 ibm introduced
kisky runtime
kisking runtime takes quantum programs
and all its dependencies
and package it in a containerized
execution environment
this environment is close to the quantum
hardware so it can reduce the latency by
creating a tight loop
and because the program runs on the
cloud
it also improves
the scalability of classical resources
but there's more than that
your programs now run in the cloud and
can get all the benefits from
of a cloud-based model
most notably ksk runtime offers a set of
tools and features
that would
make quantum computing easier for
developers
it has a number of predefined routines
such as
circuit optimization lot remaps the
gates in your circuits so they would run
faster
similar to what modern compilers do
circuit result post-processing law will
take all those measured ones and zeros
and
convert them into higher level
representation such as expectation
values
and
the last one is error mitigation
law gives you higher quality results
the error mitigation is especially
important because quantum hardware today
is not perfect
and the raw results often contain errors
so without error mitigation you wouldn't
be able to get the correct results back
so how do you actually access cascade
runtime
the answer is simple you use kiskit
kit has a package that allows you to
send your entire quantum program
including both the quantum and classical
piece into this execution environment
thanks for watching
if you have any questions please leave
them in the comments below also please
remember to like this video and
subscribe to our channel so we can
continue to bring you content that
matters to you